find and they start with this the
coordinates of the center of a square so
pause you can picture what a square
looks like right it looks like that
right and we were to find where the
middle is okay keep reading of a square
weird and then they have this fancy word
vertices which is just kind of a
technical term for corners right so it's
it's the point that define the shape
okay with vertices and then they list
out these coordinates right right
everything check out okay so that's all
the information we've got there's a
square we want to find the center and
then these are where all the corners are
okay so here's my approach
it doesn't say draw a diagram however a
diagram is so useful it's so beneficial
it helps you literally get the picture
and also actually will help you work out
what's the fastest way to do this so I'm
going to draw a set of axes and I'm
gonna plot these on I'm not gonna do it
beautifully just enough so I can get the
idea okay
so let's have a go at this and you
should follow along with me sure up a
set of axes for yourself okay and I'm
gonna go one by one and I'm going to
plot these points okay so I've got a
which is at the origin like so okay okay
where's bb2 for that means I go to the
right two units and then I'll go up four
units
now I'm just going to pause for a second
because this is interesting
I've only draw these two points but this
certainly doesn't look like the square
that I drew at the beginning right like
look it's off at an angle like if I join
these up it's not gonna be nice and
flush like this okay so let's keep on
drawing and see what happens um see if
that six - okay so 6 2 would be 1 1 2 3
4 5 6 I just made it yeah that's right
there's C okay my last one is D so
that's 4 1 2 3 4 and negative 2 beads
down right negative 2 right so it looks
like it's around C like oh right now I
can see the square but it's like tilted
let's let's join it up so that you can
see yeah probably like be my scale is
not perfect either so a rhombus is not
an unlikely kind of figure to get
actually I think that looks like what
I'm getting it's square-ish anyway hey
you guys have got a grid book so you can
actually do it properly oh yeah this is
three is three okay so now I've got my
square right now can you see how useful
it is to know where all the coordinates
are right because if I wasn't know where
the center is where is the center like I
guess I'm expecting it somewhere like in
here or something right that's like the
center now how do I find this how do I
find the coordinates of the center of
this square ah okay now we'll get to the
edge for a second I'm interested in how
we get there because that's really
important now can you see so I'm gonna
find a big point but the question is
midpoint of what
that's alright now you can see for
example if I do the midpoint between a
and B I'll be here that is not the
center of the square I could do the
midpoint of B and C and I will be here
and that is not the center on it or not
right
where should I go yeah okay good so I've
got two options here I can go AC and I
might just and you like my like to do
this as well I'm gonna drain that up a
go okay so that's one of the diagonals
right because it's a square or even if
it was a rectangle actually if I take
the other diagonal as well it should
also line up right there at that at the
center of the square that guy so you
have two options and both will be fine
you can take the midpoint of a and C
that guy or alternatively you could take
the midpoint of B and D this guy and you
should get the same answer okay question
and you've got to be careful I see what
you're getting at I'm you've gotta be
careful because it's because of a tyre
let me come back over here
the reason why it sort of worked
overhears because everything was nice
and everything was you know directed
verdict or directly horizontal but here
you're offered an angle right which
makes it you can't just say oh this
x-coordinate this external be the same
so well they're not because yeah they're
twisted I tell that's just very quickly
rehearse this and see how we go because
I've got my formula written down here
I'm not gonna write it all over again
but let's do a and C here's a and here's
C okay now all I'll ask you in a second
why you think why I think the AC is
actually a much better option than BD
I'll do both of them for you to prove it
but there's a clear reason why a C's
better see if you spot as we go through
I'm gonna do the exit of the wives right
so I've got six plus zero on to that's X
1 plus X 2 now do y 1 plus y 2 that's up
to plus zero on to you see that and this
brings us back to our table set which is
3 1 yeah tell me why okay so the first
reason is our curse I like to avoid
negatives wherever I can
okay and if you have a choice you should
too because it makes you it's an extra
place for errors to creep you is the
first thing but there's a second even
more interesting reason look at a a is
not just any point it's a special point
what is it it's the origin right it's 0
0 which means that when you do maths
with it like when you put 0 into things
it's super easy everyone could do 6 plus
0 it's 6 right and so it's almost like
the bed to work is far reduced if you
can never get zeros if you can ever get
0s without getting dust in your hair
then
then you should use them okay now just
really quickly just a satisfy that does
work will do BD anyway okay BD of these
two coordinates so I'm gonna get 2 + 4 2
plus negative 2 that's still 6 over 2
which is still 3 and that's still 0
wait what sigh this is for its for sorry
that should be a hole so that's that's
still 2 over 2 which yeah because like
we said their growth is a set at the
center okay but but AC is a better
choice
okay so a diagram super helpful not
necessary